[Musique]
sans famille
c'est rémy rémy au hasard des chemins
la vie les passe au jockey pour un gamin
en deux matches
il rencontre quelques fois le bon
un billard ou bien le pauvre petit perdu
comme lui
ça rassure
toujours sur terre
tél
en bonne
le destin
ainsi le fait
pour leap year une han
amis
sous la neige bulleux ou sous le grand
soleil
ses yeux brillent
l'arme l'espoir ou l'oeuf à grains sans
pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
viens vite mais qu'est ce que t'as
montremy ria connaît la maison
il veut parler à l'heure actuelle
toujours sur terre
salutaire
sans bonheur
le défunt
sora
il le fait
olivier
pas
en famille
sous la neige je veux le haut sous le
bras
saleh
c
sans pavés
mais qu'est ce qui t'a dit il m'a rien
dit on m'a dit que je voulais être voir
c'est tout c'est vous la mère barbara
ben oui c'est pourquoi ben voilà c'est
pour votre mari c'est juste un malheur
je suis pas trop quoi vous dire moi il a
eu un accident sur le chantier il ya un
échafaudage qui s'est effondré enfin on
sait pas trop comment lui il travaille
est juste en dessous en ont il sentira
il est vivant c'est le principal mais
c'est pour ses jambes
pour le moment il est à l'hôpital comme
je rentre au pays il m'a demandé de vous
annoncer sa part faut que j'aille le
voir
non c'est pas la peine ça serait plutôt
un embarras qu'autre chose mais il aura
besoin d'argent pour son procès son
procès contre le patron ils veulent rien
lui payer ils ont dit c'est de votre
faute
fallait pas rester sous les échafaudages
lui c'était mieux où on lui avait dit
sceaux m mais allez prouver ça met des
sous on en a pas à maman
theremin ton père ça va faire dix ans
qu'il est parti et c'est pas parce qu'il
est jamais venu me voir qu'il pensait
pas nous puis tout ce temps il nous a
toujours envoyé de l'argent pour ça
qu'on vivre dans la misère alors
maintenant c'est lui qui a besoin de les
comprendre alors des sous on trouve et
vous n'avez pas d'autres man ça va pas
vous faire défaut fois
c'est que je pourrai jamais la revendre
ça c'est une vache de pauvres c'est par
voie et c'est une bonne vache
ah si c'est toi qui le dit mon petit va
enfin c'est bien pour vous rendre
service à pendre loire mais je pouvais
pas vous en donner plus à l'est à la
prochaine
et bon courage à lui
s'appelle la roussette c'est parce qu'il
va revenir papa ça je sais pas d'abord
qu'on le soigne il faut qu'il a mis son
procès après ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est heureux
au tessin
oui quand la lettre enquête
[Musique]
voir
dans sa fable ii
[Musique]
soudain vous plaît
nous c'est rien
c'est
[Musique]
chaque jour
et
[Musique]
on le sert de ma part
à
ami jamie vient voir la farine ou tu
l'as eu j'ai emprunté à la mer cassagne
regarde sur la ruche
mais qu'est ce que tu vois des pales des
oeufs du lait du cir du beurre c'est
pour quoi faire
on la devine qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
avec tout ça je sais pas georges bien
des galettes nouveau décret allez tu vas
me faire une bonne flambée mon devis de
chercher des petits voire qui sait c'est
toi
bassi voix me flatte aussi croyez plus
géré on s'y croyait de but
je ne peux plus
quinze jours que je marche ta jambe j'ai
la pâte raid
ils veulent plus de moi ce chantier ça
fait rien ça fait plaisir ici sur 20
arrêts pour moi qui s'est fâché toi pas
jérôme c'est rémy rémy mais tu m'avais
dit je suis arrivé j'ai vu j'ai pas pu
alors qu'il m'a pas écouté ou à leurs
fins j'ai rien dans le ventre depuis
hier y'a quoi pour s'oublie pas grande
chose c'est qu'on attendait pas et ça
oui oui je peux faire une omelette et
payé à la soupe lui de rester planté là
mais dans les assiettes
oui
prochaine perdu dans l'assaut les seuls
au top enfin gmac il coupe la visite on
sait pas ce que je lui avais promis
décret allait finir dans l'assiette et
va te coucher à lui effectué logement il
a passé en bas il n'a pas l'air costaud
qu'on s'engage t pas su jérôme il est
très bien implanté ce gamin jamais
malade jamais rien tu es si gentil au
gentil gentil c'est pour ça qu'il va lui
donner à manger de dieu pourquoi t'as
pas fait ce que tu avais dis donc c'est
pas une courage parce que c'est facile à
dire mal lu à l'hospice elle faire c'est
autre chose figure toi tout ce que je
sais c'est que ce gamin il n'est pas à
nous et pas ça mais je suis pas super au
vrai mais qu'ils apprennent aujourd'hui
pour cheyrou comme ça tu as changé la
ville
avant tu aurais jamais parlé comme ça au
point de petites gouttes
et jusqu'au bourg barricades il faut un
jour tu te remets pas toi
moi c'est pas moi ce qu'il a dit était
ma maman rôtissait montremy même temps
que je voulais pas mais c'est pareil de
mon petit garçon apparaît comme si je
t'avais fait tu as menti
il est alors ma voix maman n'en sais
rien on la connaît pas c'est jérôme
quitte à trouver un atteint paris en
allant au travail
il a entendu un bébé qui pleurait c'est
être alors voilà on a gardé mais
pourquoi il m'a gardé beaucoup et veut
garder à je te raconterai ça une autre
femme moment je veux pas aller à
l'hospice non mais non barbezat sera là
tu vas pas l'hospice
[Musique]
alors réveilles tu viens tu verras bien
aller avec toi maman barbara noire et
dense est fausse vertu pluzz quoi ce que
tu pas le choix
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai envie de prendre
on
non
allez hop
[Musique]
de l'argent de l'argent mais mon bon ami
de l'argent qui voulez vous qu'ils vous
en donne enfin cet enfant c'est vous qui
avait décidé de le garder de lui bien
vous doutez que ça allez vous faire une
bouches de plus à nourrir alors oui mais
je croyais qu'un jour ou l'autre on
allait bien belle réclamé mois le
commissaire il a dit que c'était
peut-être un enfant volée alors si henin
qui voulaient bien se charger du bébé il
y aura une grosse récompense à l'appui
une grosse récompense
bah oui vu que les parents c'était comme
qui dirait des rupins il avait des
dangers dentelle tout ça dames
moi j'ai dit que j'étais preneur et on
pas vu vous n'en avez jamais vu la
couleur qu'un petit tu veux aller jouer
dans la cour et du soleil vient nous a
pas écoutés vous avez adopté l'enfant
si vous ne voulez plus donc il n'y a
aucune loi qui vous force à regarder et
c'est pour ça ou bien le garder avec ma
femme mais si ce qui m'a coûté pendant
11 ans rend mon cher monsieur vous êtes
libre de choisir soit vous garder
l'enfant soit vous nous confiez ici un
hospice mais vous n'aurez pas un sou
mais ces gamins arrivent les nourrit je
les habille et c'est normal qu'on me
donne quelque chose c'est juste non
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise est un procès d'administration
[Musique]
pourquoi tu pleures ottoman moelle et
par qui tu veux que je te raconte une
histoire un ouais rien
il était une fois une princesse dans son
jardin merveilleux elle qu il ya une
fleur quand tout à coup un monstre
survie avec l'un des cayes et cracher du
feu par la bouche c'était mais la
princesse criait au secours mais le
prince qui passait par là
il descend de son cheval une flèche et
tire le monstre reçoit la flèche
à la maison
[Musique]
j'aime ça la gnôle toi tu penses et des
rubans c'est à cause de ces gens là que
je peux plus travailler ne pourrais me
c'est pour toi
et comme je t'ai vu été surpris c'est
énorme à nantes où se mettre à ma place
encore si tu étais mon fils dudit pont
et là je peux vent c'est quand on n'a
pas de quoi
qui se regarde c'est quoi le singe le
célèbre jolicoeur le général jolicoeur
il a conquis les indes la sibérie à la
patagonie à lui tout seul ça c'est mon
cas pis mon chien sauteur de mettre le
haut ça c'est dans chez dolce la plus
belle mais paresseuse et gerbino phrase
elvino petit serbie non le roi de la
valse bien connu tous les trois dans
toutes les cours d'europe
sans compter les basses-cours lui que
vous gêne j'en avais assez qui m'arrive
de penser ça bah oui parce que
côté tu sais marcher moi c'est pas grave
mais ça veut rien dire
il est costaud pour voir et me assieds
toi ou la bouche
et puisqu'il dit ouais c'est voir le
bain la porte mongie gauche
wendel moi quoi va mener le moi et qui
me dit vous avez l'argent rien dans les
mains rien dans les poches
au nom du dal et et quoi j'ai basta cosi
au masters
je traîne la patte était pas estropiés
comme la bri il a déjà fatigué ça promet
c'est ta maison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu t'es ce cas la boîte tu pourras
jamais chanté et milito s'était fait mal
puisqu'on fait le même chemin
autant faire la route ensemble
[Musique]
avant j'avais un autre gamin le petit
francesco joly l'a voulu se sauver et
capi la mort du cifor ne pourrait plus
marcher
j'étais obligé de l'abandonner dans la
forêt et maintenant tu ici je crois bien
que le loup il a mangé à les jolis
coeurs
ces deux mots je vous aurez perdu votre
argent propos
toi tu sais que tu me plais du piaggio
avec la voix
arrive tu t'en ailles finita times
[Musique]
amy va bientôt leur jeune âge et leur tu
sais la ligne rémy et bep cap il lui il
sait se gardent rapide à ce quota mais
capi et un match où non tout est ok what
she observé 3 il est 7 heures pour venir
mais tu peux pas le dire avant mais
pourquoi tu as peur de moi regarde moi
[Musique]
et me c'est lé symbole fort mal aimé la
cause importante dans notre métier c'est
le pied ma vraie et pierre tuquoi
l'artiste n'en un saltimbanque que le
rêve la poésie
il faut attirer l'oeil sinon qui nous
regarde personne
les gens ils passent sans nous voir
c'est beau comme un coq
je m'étais un peu les chaussures pas mal
non
va maintenant on va essayer de trouver
un sac pour toi est là mais ça donne là
dedans ayez pas peur dieu veille
nous avons des 25 le général jamais sait
combien cette merveille pour nous une
vieille read me te plaît c'est pour toi
j'aimerais retrouvaient pour la vie
j'aimerais retrouver l'italie son ciel
tué sa mère et ses chansons dans l'aude
elle me donne le frisson
j'aimerais garder dans la mémoire
il me plaît de ces belles histoires
[Musique]
total va qu'en tant le bruit des
feuilles ces palabres qui bouge tu sais
c'est le vent il le fait bouger s'il a
bien essayé de bouger ça donne quoi
aucun doute l'écrêtement sinistre
affreux c'est pareil quand tu joues la
musique
si tu essayes de jouer la musique ça
donne rien il faut laisser faire le vent
le vent y passe dans l'école tu sais
chanter les mit alors à ce qu'on écoute
et tu les paies ta p moi j'écoute bien
j'aimerais retrouver pour la vie
j'aimerais retrouver mon avis eh ben tu
sais pas chanter la vois tu compenses
est comme une source d'eau très pur ça
fait rien je me tâte ram allez on y va à
la route est longue
rapidshare bino aller general à anyama à
les salles ferment à les saletés au
début tu vas juste faire le comédien
jamais fait ça moi eh bien tu feras
celui qui est plus bête que les bêtes
tu fais celui qui s'est bien fait mais
les chiens et a peintes au jeu le valais
ridicule alors on dit le ridicule tue
c'est des sonnettes nous ça nous fait
vivre quand tu regardes et tu fais après
exactement comment un alors tu fais
l'étonnement la peur et la joie elle
monte un âge où elle parle des tripes
tu as inventé elle monte ça monte à
manquer heureux le bonheur c'est le plus
beau métier du monde
bien joli coeur maintenant moi je vais
t'apprendre de la parade alors tu te
mets là et tu me regardes la parade
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs je
vais avoir l'insigne honneur de vous
présenter pour la première fois en
france notre célèbre troupe est tout
d'abord honneur aux dames et demoiselles
dj pas au barreau la poubelle et la pio
d'hollandais la più pas les 16
et voici signaux graphiques ainsi dans
le tapis on tient au lit comme un autre
chien qui saute de métro terre dans un
ciel sont et voici mesdames et messieurs
une attraction exceptionnelle du cinoche
albino serbie non le roi dans la vente
en même temps c'est mademoiselle avec
l'impératrice d'autriche
si coin comme dans l'assistance veut
apprendre la valse monsieur gilles
guinot est à sa disposition
refoulement six ans personne à monsieur
est ce que monsieur vous voulez
apprendre la valse avec zebina assez
monsieur vous allez apprendre avant le 5
janvier monsieur comment monsieur rémy
je les nie vous allez apprendre la valse
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs je
demande un encouragement péril si
l'heure est à l'émotion et demi et elle
s'est passionnée givati native
[Musique]
la vérité vous faites des primes à ses
limites
ah c'était très bien monsieur vous
faites des preuves et fabuleux fabuleux
gelabale s'est éteint continue et c'est
très bien
mesdames et messieurs je demande un
encouragement pour le petit lobby et la
grange qui est là vous avez des rallyes
mais elle est pour toi ton est donné
c'est papa qui l'a dit ah bon oui
pourquoi mettre le feu à la croche part
dit tiens ma belle est allé me faire un
jeu devient alors regarde bien là bas je
te fais la lumière regarde bien la barre
qu'est ce que tu vois tournoi alors
imagine une petite bougie avec une
petite flamme qui brûle durée voir
oui à ne ment pas un comédien ça ment
jamais y a pas pire de rome pour une
comédienne si tu vois rien tu dis je
vois rien mais tu fais pas semblables
allez on recommence alors fixé bien
là-bas ouvre les yeux grand le plus fort
possible
très glam qu'est ce que tu vois n'a rien
du tout maintenant ça va venir tout seul
une petite flamme
de brillantes
c'est clair pas beaucoup mais quand même
d'une voix
tout roule
la terre et celle de voile en feu
un beau frère qui craquent qui pétillent
tu l'entends le feu qui pétille ça
chauffe un toi tu as le d'en tuer la loi
ouais non seulement ce tour
cela va faire un mois et marche sur les
robes et elles ne seront pas de longs
séjours
il faut toujours marché
marché coûte que coûte
que les regards
shaw dénudées
pas de me
[Musique]
oh
des sous
les aider
[Musique]
c'est pas comment elle va faire qu'on ne
laboure la mère barbara notamment qu'un
casque et mon billet tombait pas trouvé
pour la vie j'aimerais retrouver
l'italie son ciel tu ramènes et ses
chansons dont l'odeur me donne le
frisson à ça brûle les doigts
rémy c'est le métier rentre maintenant
tu chantes toi tu prends ta première
notre vas-y vas-y chante
j'aimerais garder dans ma mémoire
la reflet de ce bal aux histoires qu'on
raconte
pendant les nuits d'été
en italie mon pays là tu allais tu es tu
prends ta respiration enchanté de quatre
coeurs
bravo bravo tu fais des progrès
magnifique
[Musique]
et paysans
toujours pas là
un jour ans ne jouera pas
près d'une église après la mue
un mot clé
[Musique]
quand tu te
oh
or les saletés à sa santé pouvait pas
rester là il faut circuler l'illustrent
le représentant de l'autorité
peut-il me montrer un règlement par
lequel il est interdit à de pauvres
baladins d'exercer leur steve activités
sur la place publique
circulez je vous ai dit vous gêner les
gens et gazelle messieurs j'attire votre
attention
est-ce que je gêne l'honorable société
tu as je ne pouvais pas
d'abord mon chien votre singe il faut
muscler tout ça c'est la loi
jamais on muselle pas la prusse y
écouter ça suffit comme ça hein
faites ce que je vous ai dit à toi c'est
tout vous venez avec nous on encourage
le blog en date c'est un succès la
célèbre troupe vitalis mesdames et
messieurs hôtes un ça va
des chiens savants maintenant j'ai eu
l'honneur et l'avantagé d'avoir un
gendarme ça va général qu'est ce que tu
en penses répète quoi il dit faut aussi
lui mettre la buse heuliez
non je fais évacuer la salle accusé vous
avez quelque chose à dire pour votre
défense
monsieur le juge pour nous autres
saltimbanques
il y à une loi quand on a l'honneur de
tenir son public
on n'a pas le droit de le décevoir mais
vous reconnaissez avoir ridiculisé et
insulté un gardien de la force publique
nous vous condamnons à deux mois de
prison ferme et à 100 francs d'amendé en
larmes
on est condamné à faire suivante deux
mois
celui de passer mais qu'est ce que je
vais faire moi le spectacle continue
tuchan vraie comédienne maintenant tu le
chef et je te confie la troupe
quand je sentirai bien cherché je compte
sur toi
[Musique]
son mari est en prison
pour combien le savent au fond c'est dur
tout seul de faire l'achat loups de
nourrir tout le monde
avec si peu large de faire venir les
braves gens morts qui parfois devant de
sa troupe pour leur faim
gagnant leurs sous qu'est ce que tu dis
j'ai des coeurs tu as faim by ap
l'acteur cafard matt a de la chance
toile c'est la belle vie tu te promènes
voilà ça fait dix ou bon poids voyez pas
le coup
c'est tout ce que j'ai
[Musique]
voilà au le voleur regardez je suis ravi
nos services
sale chien n'a pas exclu que j'en fasse
maintenant ce avocate soul brioche oui
mais je l'espère à l'éffigie quand vas
tu as de la chance que j'appelle par les
gendarmes au moins la brioche quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'il ya un voleur par nous
qu'elle se montre aller j'attends allez
allez qui se montre j'attends serbie
dont aller ou quoi aller ou quoi il
reste là bas au fond de la cabane voilà
bon allez maintenant va donner à manger
tiens tapie est à toi heisser bideau à
yvias cervélo et bien aller voir
ailleurs mais c'est la chance que j'ai
pas fan non serbie nous revient pas
katia que vous allez voir maintenant le
plus célèbre chien monde fait face à
bernard tapie à la capuche de succès
rome
par ailleurs 20 ans
aussi complet
[Applaudissements]
régnât
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
young qui va bien avec des chez un singe
non non je viens vue ils sont at-il tu
peux sortir à l'élection on y va
merci monsieur o demain à temps merci
beaucoup
tu m'as manqué le petit singe dans les
mains oh non je peux pas il en les gens
qui connais pas non non non non non
meilleur tu renonces en tout sur de
maladie ces bêtes là qu'est ce que veut
dire le moment et toute façon je suis
déjà malade à l'eau quel enfant gâté ou
fait mammy mammy comme si demain kikwete
a laissé aller ça paye
et bravo jolicoeur encore des symptômes
allez encore une fois saluer voilà merci
monsieur merci madame mais ils peuvent
rester encore un peu avec nous cette
fois ils peuvent descendre un peu plus
loin sur le canard sur violence mais
s'ils savaient pas en vous allez moi
n'importe où costumes un endroit qui me
plaît je m'arrête là non on vous emmène
au oui oui oui
[Musique]
-
quoi
enfin fort médicaments
[Musique]
comme équipe nous
s'il est d'accord
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
pourquoi duteau pas non et toi non plus
je suis content tu sais que tu sois là
moi aussi je suis content montfaucon
normes mais oui je lis que va pas sans
lui mais n'inquiète pas comment ça
spectacle jamais at endormir toujours
comme ça le soir je te choper la part de
quoi diminuer pendant la nuit
et puis je me demande pas compte mais
pourquoi tu veux mourir
y'a pas de raisons tu meurs si ce n'est
pas monsieur j'ai très mal à tu sais à
tabac l'air on s'assoit pas mais
j'aimerais quand même
est ce que c'est pour ça que je plante
le temps le médicament cd vaty peut
dormir je suis là puis si je vois que tu
meurs je te réveilles ray mais il vous
savez c'est un travail que je vous
demande vous seriez payer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
mais tu tu l'as pas de parents aussi
gym un bambin l habitat chabanon à elle
a une belle maison papa
non il est mort il était maçon il est
tombé d'un toit
mais pourquoi tu n'es pas rester comment
tu t'y as chabanon c'est moi maman
barbara elle a demandé à vitaly square
mon maître de m'expliquer le métier de
saltimbanque
tu sais j'avais un petit garçon de
tournage il est en angleterre
il est mort oui oui elle et moi alors
maintenant je n'ai plus car ça pas moi
je trouve car tu as une charge beaucoup
en ce moment
oui c'est vrai depuis que tu es là tu ça
est remis
j'ai envie d'écrire à tous mais pour
quoi faire
pour lui dire que je te garde avec moi
au nom de madame c'est pas possible il
faut pas au nom il faut pas vous
comprenez il est pas allé voir sa
famille il est en prison
[Musique]
sur les 4,5 g
non j'ai rien
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à tapis du là les voleurs de chiens hall
caddie miseria honte à toi en france du
malheur jeter a tenu à la faute de la
toussaint
j'étais attendu toute la nuit j'ai cru
que tu t'es mort tu m'avais minière
c'est ça mais tu me reconnais en moins
c'est que je croyais que ces facéties
vit pas pour moi j'ai compté les jours
j'ai compté les heures et toi tu l'as tu
te places comme eux que je trouve pas le
mot mais je veux dire je croyais qu'il y
ait encore du temps vous allez venir
c'est parce que tu as madame elle m'a
écrit regarde un ari balogh belge je
trouve ça il paraît que c'est fini
maintenant tu en de bonnes mains et nous
deux il faut plus qu'un seul moi jamais
et tout dépend quand je te parle je te
fais rentrer assez ça tu as honte de
voir un c'est pas la peine que je me
présente et vous devinez qui je suis
le montreur de chiens qui a perdu ses
chiens que j'allais voulait rendre vos
chiens et rémy aussi vous alliez me le
rendent surtout que vous êtes assez
bonne forme écrit nous vous joindre au
cas où la somme elle convient pas être
moi moi quand je vois un enfant j'ai au
moins la politesse de disparaître et vos
os avec bosso vous vous croyez qu'on
perd non seulement voilà la somme
la somme elle convient pas combien
voulez vous je veux rémy écoutez soyez
raisonnable cet enfant je peux lui
donner une éducation
il est une chance de pouvoir devenir
gomis eu qu un canari en cage
je n'ai jamais traité rami comme
domestiques et qui est doux à la fin
pour me parler ce temps qui vous êtes
avec vos airs de grande dame tout
sentait la mort tout votre bateau il pue
la mort avec ses chevaux qui le tire
comme un corbillard lui il est vivant
on va dans des vivants
vivant
[Musique]
oh
e
à
tu te rends compte
il est sorti de prison et moi j'étais
même pas la girouette pas être parti
avec le lien dit tendu non écoute taupin
violon nous jeu tant mieux s'ils
écoutent bien me tuer
ah non c'est sûr que c'est lui
[Musique]
tu sais me moi ta place je ferais pareil
vas-y voiture je n'oublierai jamais moi
non plus je n'oublierai jamais et dit tu
vas pas mourir tu me jure bien sûr
sais tu dire à ta maman tu lui diras un
vide umih pas vite
marcy arthur merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chiens il s'enrichira qui sent
habité 10e la vie décalée qui cela et
nous n'avons même pas le plus tard y est
allé rallyes pilotes soit tu sais tout
votre santé toi comment il va joli col
et je suis un vieil égoïste allez un
diamant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hiver est là
le vent y du les oies sauvages
dans le ciel de vie à dieu le temps béni
vous sur le patron d'eon
sage comme une image
[Musique]
je vois les noms
avec
[Musique]
rémy la neige ne recommence on va les
passer l'hiver à la ville tous les deux
cela bien sauf les noailles
kissi arrive tu as changé
on se parle plus jamais vous donner
comme des étendues vous aussi vous avez
changé
d'ici là plusieurs challenges pas les
gens ou alors c'est moi je vous vois
plus pareil avant vous citiez tout pour
moi vous étiez au bon dieu avec votre
vélo maintenant jeune homme comme tout
le monde
ah oui c'est ça
m
[Musique]
je les lourds
ça c'est le bas
les 20 salles
[Musique]
les pêches et rémy
e
et
je sais c'est dur mais on arrive à l'est
[Musique]
je
comme moi la ville vers un endroit en
abyme deux jours peut-être 3
mais toute cette neige tu sais je sais
plus j'ai perdu je sais pas je sais plus
je sais plus où est la route
allez courage voire vinci
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on l'aimé
regarde la cabane à lait 8 les chiens
l'interview de chauffer
allez allez rentrer
tu vas pas tomber malade petit bonhomme
tu crois qu'il ya froid a tissé rémy
c'est pas un climat pour lui ça écoute
écoute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
tu crois qu'ils vont venir avec le feu
et luz à apple du feu ils vont orner
autour de la cabane toute l'année et
quand le julien les loups ils partent
mais mais mais mais ce qui l'est c'est
ton tour maintenant et je suis fait vous
allez à l'éveil toi allez ça va tu fais
attention le feu s'éteint pas
[Musique]
ta photo s'il allait au partage
dans l'ensemble les pma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense
dolce germinon et toi tu te dois me dit
tu t'es pendant le même auteur donc
selby nous hissons je ne sais pas je
sais pas tiens allez viens avec moi
prendre sa poule a le mérite bien
les terminaux des terminaux
dans le che
[Musique]
et pourtant tous les 1 200 kg 6 3
regardez m
le tablier
oui police ouimette il faut sauver
quant à lui
c'est foutu
lucas pas le jour
[Musique]
e
encore
[Musique]
regarde et par là
le papa allait bien même hiver vite et
nous non plus par la tâche des traces
après un rush la salle blanche l'a bien
joli comme bien des cas il ya là bien là
bien là mais pas par alex wiens au
chaudron décrite salut n'est pas passée
moi c'est habitalys déplacer l'atome est
ici
[Applaudissements]
comme rémy j'ai pu ton âge tu sais aller
pardon monsieur est ce que nous pouvons
avoir une grande chambre bien chauffé le
contraire
ça ne marche pas si elle marche
ce n'est pas notre bagage mais non vous
voyez bien oui même les rechanges
dauphin label sont à la charge du
dauphin j'ai dit mémé tu mets tout une
jolie keun ho cho moi je vais chercher
un auteur bien au chaud mais voilà ça
passera va c'est pas mon nous rachid
s'est encore besoin de toi
oui entrée 10 h d'ang lee
m comptant un patron tient
merci julie club a dû son monte à
bestioles tient pas c'est pareil on dit
donc si c'est vitaly ce qu'il est dit
faut que tu bois bien chaud voilà
docteur jolicoeur alors oui les notes
malades
c'est ça votre enfant en train
d'agoniser 1,1 selon lui c'est le
saint-james elle est soignée de saint
jouin docteur si je vous avais dit c'est
un singe vous seriez pas venu non
vraiment je ne veux pas y aller il ya
des vétérinaires pour ça dr je vous en
supplie faites quelque chose soigner le
jeu vous plaît
[Musique]
il va mordre on a remis les paraphes
limiter qu'à la pâte molle la fièvre
c'était une fiction de poitrine il c'est
grave très grave
ouais mais bon je vais faire ici combien
giroud doit docteur j'ai pas l'habitude
veut faire payer et quand je sois bien
sage avoir monsieur écoute moi bien une
jolie colle avec les mii on va donner
une représentation tu bouges pas surtout
tu crois qu'il veut venir avec nous là
tu sais tu sais tu es malade tu peux pas
venir le petit bonhomme
sinon tu vas mourir tu comprends mourir
allez tu resteras bien sage a les balles
ennemies bien plus vite on n'y va plus
vite c'est à l'écart dit obama qui vient
de leaker sur les que courage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
s'est porté sur 8 go vanelli taille
c'est voter ici ce niveau marne et la
gioia ses prothèses 600 thierry tour
profumo aux bizots nyonnais le modèle
tour auxerre
mais ricco
docomo nautique astoria
à ma scène très visible qui est drôle
tchèque et più bella c'est beauté si
rythme malgré la vita au tampon
m
hé hé
et toi
le spectacle est terminé
les chandelles qui la leur faim il ne
faut pas abuser de leur patience ni de
la vôtre j'espère que vous êtes content
et que vous en avez eu pour votre argent
attendez écoute moi avant de partir vous
allez rentrer chez vous bien au chaud
vous allez parler du vieux fou du gamin
du chien savant vous ne parlez pas du
singe
parce que le singe vous n'avez pas vu et
pourtant
il est là il y a que lui ici ils
prennent toute la place
le général joe little qui a conquis les
end à lui tout seul c'est pourquoi je
vous demande de l'applaudir téléphone de
l'applaudir à vous emmener concélébrée
de l'applaudir à vous crever les tympans
vous m'entendez
maintenant des mois une seconde et
madame attentats
pardonnez moi de vous déranger je
voulais seulement vous féliciter vous
allez mes revenus enchantés
je vous remercie vous êtes italien n'est
ce pas oui madame
savez vous quittez carlo bonini non je
connais pas moi c'était la plus belle
voix de toute l'italie
nous l'avons souvent t'applaudir la
scala avec mon mari c'est bien possible
quand je vous ai entendu tout à l'heure
j'ai vu que c'était lui
ça m'a tout de suite rapide et bien vous
faites erreur
excusez moi madame je suis pressé
on attend attentivement remercie
beaucoup madame merci merci tu as fait
ce qu'elle m'a donné à louis d'or est
morte en carlo balzani femmes halte au
tempo
[Musique]
à l'école
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au fur
et
et que c'est ma petite colère
quelques
macao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
et
on
mais où on voit
nous sommes au score
au prince aucune podium on aurait pu
longtemps haïtienne je crois c'est ici
un combat se séparait pourquoi vitalis
pourquoi pourquoi
il ya plus les chiens
comment tu vas faire un tour avec celui
là qui fait que plus ni j'ai cherché les
deux autres monsieur marquant même si
d'y jouer un peu mieux peut-être
voilà aussi j'étais aveugle ou moins
l'eau salée j'avais plein de pitié vous
allez bonne abandonné juste pour la
mauvaise saison je vais acheter deuxième
je vais les délaissés et au printemps on
apprend dans l'eau tous les deux en
italie
ma bière partout tu verras en patagonie
tu veux en patagonie tous les deux dans
le dos messieurs
même si le revenu chez lui une fille
laurie m'étonnerait vous avez toujours
ici
alors il ya un bout de temps vous savez
où on peut le trouver au cimetière
le croise autant violer s'il est pas là
[Musique]
si tu étais d annoncer pas la peine je
montrais n'y étant pas trop mais il est
là ah non il est pas là il est sorti il
va bientôt revenir
en attendant voici vous et ricardo en
verve sur quoi ces mondiaux vas y mon
transfert comme ça c'est être le parent
ne dira rien tu les perds à ba3 ou trois
coups de fouet à un signe hors d'italie
ce qu'elles vont vendre où ça mène
j'étais venu voix lynch et les hommes à
la peau vieux vous êtes au courant oui
on la retrouvait sur le pavé il était
pas bauer joue dixon allumettes
elle sent le souffre animal est aussi
qui a fait ne coupons pas de danger on
ne saura jamais mais dites moi ça fait
des années qu'on ne s'est pas vu vous
n'avez pas chargé du tout hein
à 26 ans ni vous aimez beaucoup à lui m
c'est quoi ce garçon le petit rémy
bonjour et mi temps à une belle heure ça
marche toujours les enfants ici et oui
forcément
on s'y attache à ses gosses j'ai essayé
de reprendre la firme en mieux ça
rapporte pas lourd vous pouvez prendre
l'ennemi pour l'hiver ils jouent bien
normal il y en a pas deux comme vous
pour former un petit musicien internet
et vous en demandez chez mais dites moi
il me revient quelque chose mais oui
mais oui assez ça je me dis c'est bien
vous aviez une grosse dette envers
ventes ces derniers commencent à une dot
le petit française qu ça ne vous dit
rien il y a trois ans 26 l'oni vous
allouez un enfant où il est vous le
savez il est mort lui le tombé dans le
puits jolie 10h26 leone et je suis poli
et moi le 7 mai 1876 le signe en italie
c'est bien vous le senior vitalis a pris
en location
le petit français secours benedetti pour
six mois et les six mois sont passés
bien là mais non non c'est toi à cette
fois allé vitalise essai c'est plus
comme avant tout a bien changé les gens
comme un sellier ni ça n'existe plus
c'est fini et toi c'est pareil tu as
déjà un pied dans la tombe
faudrait pas trop de pousser tu si ça
intéresserait sûrement à la police de
savoir comment le petit français squibb
peut-être bien que quelqu'un d'un
poussin et ben il ya une bourrique sont
arrachés la langue tu comprends ce que
je veux dire
quintura rémy qui comprend ricardo
apporte moi une bonne assiette de soupe
le vieux refrain oui pas grande tout de
suite la route a été longue à dépêche
toi là allez quoi tu as ou tu veux pas
que hier sa feria bata pas faim et ben
ouais t'as souple bwa bwa bwa a pu voir
une heure et demie ils aiment se la
bonne soupe encore à la tiens tu pour
apprendre l'art peut elle vaut pas un
clou là et si jamais tu passes par là tu
peux toujours monter ça nous fera
plaisir parlerait rémy y aura toujours
une bonne assiette de soupe pour un
vieil ami de vingt ans et léonie
bon alors maintenant les enfants on va
régler son compte 1 mathieu à montlignon
le cahier bon allez approchez vous
approchez bon public et sa pub et non
par qui on commence toi sur les mains de
tes poches ta bouche bée ware ta bouche
tu comprends il ya des petits malins qui
cache les choux dans la bouche là bas
combien tu as passé bien ce sens où en
plus du conte bon à partir d'aujourd'hui
tu m'apportes 3,40 sens où tous les
jours ça doit aller au suivant tu me
dois de sous-toiture les un premier pour
aujourd'hui
décidément t'as pas de chagrin à les
enlève ton gilet maintiens mon mignon
les lanières
non attends attends un peu tu seras
peut-être pas le seul ça fait toujours
plaisir un peu de compagnie
il y en a d'autres qui manque des sous
lever le doigt levé le doigt lui au plus
haut que ça
[Musique]
à l'école ils viennent
asie tout en ligne c'est pourtant pas
que tu travailles enfants avant que
c'est pas comme vous la guérite année
mais brisée par exemple sur riesch à ses
pieds trop pietro tu sais que ça me fait
du mal de 80 ans a grillé le feu déchire
la peau est écrit m'arrache les oreilles
alors maintenant pour chaque cri un coût
deux fois en plus ça te paraît justement
si seulement tu avais un peu de
tendresse pour moi tu t'amuseras pas me
rendre malade de chagrin
allez vas-y maintien
kobe tu vois 4
demain
du contrat
[Musique]
bon
tapas my rémy bien près de moi un moment
bien
tiens il fallait cocher se charger pas
besoin de toi bien rémi viens t'asseoir
là tu sais
tu sais rémy je me sens très seul oui tu
me diras il ya tous les enfants et dans
la journée joué à plein de gens
n'empêche que je me sens bien ça c'est
votre faute
ben oui si vous y étiez pas si méchant
j'ai des raisons d'être méchant s'est
appliqué du non c'est pas moi des gamins
depuis le temps j'en ai ma tête de
toutes les sortes et après ils
deviennent doux comme des agneaux
maintenant c'est fini ils me dégoûtent
ce que j'aime c'est au début quand ils
résistent et toi je sens qu'avec toi ça
va pas être facile à c'est pourquoi je
voulais te parler s'il m'arrive un jour
dit dur avec toi je t'aime beaucoup ému
je veux tu le saches
c'est vrai que très beau tout de suite
quand je t'ai vu je t'ai trouvé très
beau as tu as aussi les beaux mais c'est
pas pareil avec lui je peux faire tout
ce que je veux tiens je vais te faire
une confidence
tu sais qu'il a tué 25 johnny tu crois
que c'est moi ces matières a dit ouais
je te fais confiance à tu le sais pas
encore des toits aussi un jour tu vas
venir manger dans la main à votre bon
coeur s'il vous plaît
qui sont ces faits
[Musique]
oui rires avec toi lui sont les autres
le travail tient dès 6 heures tu as
dormi tout cas journée six heures du
soir rien aux folies a dit pat révélé
confident
demain il faudra que tu travailles comme
tout le monde un bon et toi il veut plus
de mettre dans la rue je ramène pas
assez d'argent alors je garde la maison
fauchon ménages pour par la soupe
tu as bien mais des fois les fermiers
avec un canal à marmite confiance il a
tort que je veux du bouillon quand il
n'est pas là pourquoi tu ne souffre pas
tu veux que j'aille passais pas t'as pas
ainsi mais c'est vrai que mangou view
pour moi tu avais la chance car ô folies
tuer a tapé dans l'oeil et c'est
maintien qui va pas être content
pourquoi il va pas être content t'as pas
vu c'est son petit chouchou sur tout et
rien dit non plus
alors ta té-ci aujourd'hui oui
aujourd'hui ça va a dit dont j'ai vu le
bus qui était avec toi hier soir je suis
parce qu'il a l'air de tourner autour de
la maison elle principal éditeur s'est
pas foulé un cigare en folie tu voyais
aller chercher ta bonne soupe
y'a combien est passé aussi d'argent non
bon tu pourra passer prendre le gamin
demain matin comme ça au moins c'est
clair
il n'aura pas froid en journée sans fin
ça va mieux belle japon patois pot de
colle
rémy maman millions tu sais pas mais
match à montreux dit comment s'est
passée 1 h et à ses fins et avoue toi
tabourin adhérons d'un plus petit toi
t'as pas tort un ordi mais devant moi tu
europe comme un ver de terre
dabou regardez le regardez le bien
approche les approcher c'est lui c'est
lui qui vous donnez du fouet mais pas
maintenant vous allez pouvoir lui faire
payer chaque jeudi coup on verra ce
qu'il en reste
rémi le fouet la fois
et bah donne donne au fouet donc il va
commencer
toi toi toi alors toi rémy tu comprends
moi je peux pas ça mais ça me fait trop
mal au coeur vas-y alors je t'aime bien
sûr j'entends regain alors tu fais ton
ménages donne moi les lanières
donne moi les lanières fait saigner
comme un fort pitt ordures
hospitalisé qu'est ce qui t'arrive fait
pour moi
[Musique]
allez pas
j'imaginais que tu avais oublié ou quoi
ces prêts pas attendre demain si jamais
été le tour je donne pas cher de ta peau
ce qu'il faut surtout c'est sortir de
cette ville je connais un endroit une
carrière dans le temps j ai couché
marchand ça ira mieux aller en avant mes
enfants
[Musique]
oui
je m'arrête là j'en peux plus n'en reste
pas là
avec cette fois ci on s'arrête on se
relève jamais aller on y est presque
bien
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ban
[Musique]
il ya personne
allez viens
allez debout j'habite à l'iss
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vitalis fini le chien ne tient chaud
c'est ma faute je ne dit que l'essai sur
le gâteau vous restez là vous savez dit
si on s'arrête on peut plus sur lever
plus tôt motards comme à bourg
j'imaginais qui fut chaud enfin sur rien
mais si m il faut essayer pour funky
petit avec de belles flâne tout jaune à
ça réchauffe dit vous voyez vous voyez
qu'est ce que vous regardez le temps
mais quoi
les loups mais kalou il n'y a pas de
l'eau dans les vies des loups blancs
[Musique]
des louvrais
en famille ou ses réunions avant des
chemins
ça en famille
la vie n'est pas toujours gai pour un
gamin
quand il marche
il rencontre quelques fois
on aime me
rien fait
ou bien le pauvre petit père lui comme
lui vivent pas traîné
toujours
je perds
solide
son bonheur
le destin
[Musique]
m
les faits
le
ce
sous la neige douce ou legrand
à l'oeil ses yeux prix
larmes des espoirs ou le madré
[Musique]